invité de ce journal les cinq astronaute
français candidats la navette spatiale
américaine dramatique épilogue d'un
enlèvement en espagne
la fille du consul de belgique a été
assassiné après le coup d'éclat de jjss
les quatre de la majorité s'en tiennent
à leur manifeste nouveau délai crédit à
la carte pour les rapatrier en attendant
l'indemnisation là messieurs bonsoir
avant toute chose je voudrais que nous
rêvions ensemble que nous rêvions sur
cette maquette du laboratoire spatial
space lab un laboratoire qui fera partie
de la navette spatiale américaine qui
doit voler dans deux heures tout cela
vous le saviez déjà mais ce que vous ne
saviez pas c'est qu'un français peut
être va voler dans l'espace et qui
d'entre nous n'a pas souhaité le faire
le centre national d'études spatiales a
retenu cinq français et les autres pays
européens ont retenu une cinquantaine
d'autres candidats et l'un d'entre eux
deviennent en 1981 le compagnon de 4
cosmonautes america et vous le voyez
dans les cinq français quatre sont du
sexe masculin tous mariés ils ont entre
31 et 40 3
et puis il y a une femme et c'est elle
que nous avons choisi de privilégier car
son aventure n'est quand même pas
ordinaire à la 32 ans est aussi mariée
et mère d'une petite fille vous êtes la
seule femme à avoir été retenu comme
astronaute à l'ouest donc si l'on
excepte valentina terechkova qui était à
soviétique est parti dans l'espace les
villes choisies je crois plus en
fonction de vos qualités intellectuelles
que de vos qualités physiques
on ne nous a pas demandé des qualités
physiques extraordinaires le cnes a
procédé entre le mois d'avril et le mois
de juillet à une série de tests qui
visait à vérifier que nous étions
parfaite santé physique en particulier
au niveau cardiaque à vérifier que dans
des conditions spéciales assez proche
des conditions que nous pourrions
rencontrer dans l'espace nous restions
en bonne santé
disons mais séparément durant l'exercice
de muscu
sur comme les superman américain nous a
fait un peu pédaler sur des petits vélos
on nous a fait courir sur un plan
incliné mais ça reste est tout à fait au
niveau d'une fable femme est ce que vous
êtes entraîné un petit peu à vivre dans
ce pays savez ce que vous connaissez
déjà et vient nous avons tous rêvé sur
ce spécial depuis un certain nombre
d'années puisque le début du projet
spécial a été lancée en 1973 et donc
d'ici la fin de l'année 1980 on peut
espérer que la navette spatiale
américaine mettra sur orbite le
laboratoire sp saab
construit par les pays de l'europe de
l'ouest
imaginez que vous soyez retenue vous
allez partir pendant très longtemps
états unis ces deux ans vous allez
partir dans l'espace ça pas vous poser
de problèmes familiaux
en fait une grande partie des décès qui
devront se faire avant parce que les
astronautes devront se spécialiser avec
les expériences sur lesquels ils
travailleront se passeront à portman en
allemagne à côté de cologne donc vous
emmène un groupe titiller avec vous
probablement bien sûr nouvelle horrible
maintenant une nouvelle que nous avons
apprise il y a deux heures à peine la
petite véronique carlier quatre ans la
fille du consul de belgique à valence en
espagne et qui avait été enlevé lundi
gala petite véronique a été assassiné
son corps a été retrouvé à une centaine
de mètres de la maison où elles avaient
été enlevées pour l'instant pas d'autres
précisions
on s'oriente pour l'instant vers le
crime d'un malade mental rien de neuf
dans l'enlèvement du président du
patronat ouest allemand monsieur
schleyer une seule certitude cet après
midi l'otage est en vie le gouvernement
allemand a décidé de ne plus donner
d'informations sur la faire pour
permettre un meilleur dialogue avec les
terroristes
la seule chose que l'on est à brive et
le report de la visite ce que le premier
ministre anglais james callaghan devait
faire en allemagne c'est dire
l'importance que bones accorda la sphère
obscurs et difficiles
le dialogue amorcé hier soir se poursuit
entre les terroristes et l'office
fédéral de la police criminelle de
wiesbaden message des ravisseurs
réponse souvent tardive des autorités
sur les chaînes de télévision il est
clair que le gouvernement ouest allemand
cherche à faire prenez les choses pour
ne pas céder aux exigences du commando
on se demande toutefois pas
combien de temps pourra durer ce petit
jeu considéré ici comme dangereux ce
matin la police criminelle a rendu
publique la lettre des ravisseurs daté
du 6 septembre
on en connaissait déjà le contenu
libération de 11 détenus de la fraction
armée rouge dont andreas baader mises à
leur disposition d'un avion versement de
100 mille marc parent prisonniers
libérés enfin deux hommes pour les
accompagner dans leur fuite
un pasteur et le secrétaire général de
la fédération internationale des droits
de l'homme auprès de l'onu et toutes les
exigences sont satisfaites en
smartphones slayer sera libéré sinon il
sera exécuté les policiers pour
l'instant ont la certitude que le
président du patronat ouest allemand est
toujours en vie la lettre des ravisseurs
était accompagné d'une photo de monsieur
flyers seconde preuve une bande vidéo
reçue hier soir par les policiers
la balle est pour l'instant dans le camp
des terroristes
l'heure des ultimatums largement dépassé
sans que le gouvernement ait fait
connaître ses intentions
c'est l'impasse quelles décisions
prendront les responsables à l'issue de
cette veillée d'armes
que peuvent ils faire alors que toute la
presse ouest allemandes qu'elles soient
de droite ou de gauche recommandent la
plus grande fermeté alors que 71 % de la
population dans un sondage estiment que
le gouvernement ne doit pas fait d la
politique d'abord l'opposition avec la
confirmation que la rencontre au sommet
des trois dirigeants de la gauche aura
bien lieu le 14 septembre c'est à dire
mercredi prochain au siège du ps on ne
peut pas dire que pour autant le climat
se soit beaucoup passé ni puisque le
socialiste claude estier rappelle assez
vigoureusement dans l'unité les
positions réelles du ps sur
l'actualisation du programme commun
aucune raison dit-il d'accepter des
accusations injustifiées de la part du
pc en face dans le camp de la majorité
est bien chacun s'efforce au mieux de
calmer les remous suscités par le pavé
de jean-jacques servan-schreiber hier
sur les marches de l'hôtel matignon
le leader radical au sortir d'une
conversation avec raymond barre il
révélait l'existence d'une coalition
anti rpr au sein de la majorité avec
caution d'elysée et chacun de démentir
l'hôtel matignon les centristes les
giscardiens dans le bureau politique se
tenait ce matin à nancy
il a été question de ratifier le
manifeste que la majorité a approuvé
lundi dernier le bureau politique à
l'unanimité a approuvé ce manifeste et
en le faisant il a manifesté une volonté
très claire elle est simple la page la
querelle au sein de la majorité est
tournée et je dirais presque
radicalement tourné
pourtant vous admettez qu'il ya eu des
rencontres entre le parti républicain et
les autres formations de la majorité à
l'exclusion du rpr il ya eu des
rencontres parce que si je dis non à la
querelle
je dis aussi oui et la différence et
donc il est normal que s'affirme dans
l'entente retrouvée de la majorité les
particularités et les originalités de
divers mouvements de la majorité donc
nous n'avons retrouvé certaines
formations mais cela ne saurait en
aucune façon être présenté comme un
front commun
et si cela devait être présenté comme un
front commun j'abandonnerai séance
tenante de dite réunion pour vous y
asseoir monsieur aussi revanche très
bien ce qu'il n'a pas tenté une
manoeuvre de division était je ne ferai
aucune déclaration qui relancerait en
quoi que ce soit
la polémique et permettez moi cette
confidence à l'avenir je mets
préoccuperait davantage de répondre aux
problèmes des français que les répondre
aux déclarations des leaders de la
majorité et la france s'en portera mieux
jacques chirac de son côté choisi c'est
la réaction par le mépris je ne veux pas
at il dit tout à l'heure en france inter
je ne veux pas engager de polémique
stérile avec les turlupins de la
politique n est peut-être pas tous comme
monsieur chirac familier avec ce mot
alors après consultation du dictionnaire
je peux vous dire qu'il a deux sens sans
une majuscule c'est le nom je cite que
l'on donne à un homme qui fait des
plaisanteries base et insipide avec une
majuscule les turlupins étaient des vers
éthique des 13ème et 14ème siècle je
vous laisse à choisir et puis il ya une
réaction à l'instant du saut servan
shreiber la politique dit il ne peut pas
se traiter avec des injures personnes à
retenir aussi que le maire de paris
estime que la majorité est unie sur
l'essentiel contrairement à l'opposition
et qu'il assistera lundi soir un dîner à
l'elysée pour la première fois depuis un
an
et puis il ya ce sondage de la sofres
publié ce matin par le figaro similaire
d'ailleurs à celui de l'institut harris
dans le matin
main qui nous confirme que à 53% contre
47%
les français ont toujours l'intention de
voter pour l'opposition en mars mais
qu'en revanche la tendance s'est
complètement inversée si on leur demande
qui va gagner
maintenant ils répondent la majorité
alors ici ont un petit peu noël copains
du débrouiller cette apparente
contradiction où il veut d'abord une
première remarque il ne faut pas
s'étonner qu'il y ait des contradictions
dans un sondage
et c'est monnaie courante un sondage ce
n'est pas un acte politique or seul un
acte politique il s'agit des décisions
des dirigeants qu'il s'agisse de
l'élection pour les citoyens est un acte
qui implique un choix clair et cohérent
donc c'est au mois de mars dans
l'isoloir que les français auront à
résoudre leurs contradictions
et si par hasard ils en ont encore alors
la situation politique de tout cela bien
la signification politique est quand
même intéressant que j'ai ce que je
viens de dire car il ya d'un côté la
stabilité politique la gauche maintient
son score un score théorique virtuel un
score de sondages d'intentions d'autres
mais un score qui est le même que celui
de février c'est à dire avant les
élections municipales
donc tout se passe comme si la querelle
la bataille entre le pc et le ps cet été
autour de l'actualisation du programme
commun avait été sans conséquence sur
les intentions de vote mais de l'autre
côté il y à ses pronostics et même ses
souhaits dans l épreuve parlais tout à
l'heure et il montre qu'il ya eu là un
retournement de situation et que le
climat psychologique a changé alors
toute la question maintenant est de
savoir si ce changement de climat
psychologique aura ou non une traduction
sur les intentions de vote aura une oui
ou non une traduction politique et une
d'un élément de réponse à la question
qui n'est pas le seul mec est un élément
important c'est la façon dont va se doit
elle se déroulait le sommet de la gauche
la semaine prochaine la façon d'une va
se dérouler ce conclut un petit ouf ce
matin chez les rapatrier en attendant la
loi d'indemnisation promise par valéry
giscard d'estaing à carpentras un décret
publié aujourd'hui au journal officiel
va leur permettre d'alléger de beaucoup
les frais qu'ils ont engagés lors de
leur installation en métropole et
contrairement à ce que certains croient
beaucoup avaient quitté l'algérie sans
le moindre sou j'ai touché un pré
installation qui s'est élevé à 11
millions 400 mille jeu par l'ancien
france 114 me sens si vous avez commencé
à leur box
j'ai remboursé pendant trois ans les
intérêts parce que sur ce prêt on a payé
des intérêts au bout de trois ans il ya
eu un moratoire
depuis je ne paye plus la mort
je pourrais pas payé actuellement dans
la situation que nous trouvons mg est
absolument impossible d'envisager
remboursement quelconque de quelque
parti que ce soit quand on souhaite
l'installation qui nous a permis de ma
permis de repartir de resservir une
famille est là et c'est assez difficile
et vous avez déposé un dossier
d'indemnisation
j'ai le projet en déposséder nation il
ya près de trois ans j'ai un récépissé
avec un appui d'instruction et un bon
numéro
quelques 3 milliards de prêts ont ainsi
été accordés entre 1962 et 1974 à
environ 28 mille familles de rapatrier
pour leur réinstallation
aujourd'hui les dettes de ces rapatriés
s'élève à environ un milliard et demi de
francs
le nouveau décret aménage tous ses prêts
il institue d'abord six commissions
paritaires régionales composées de sept
représentants de rapatrier cet aux
fonctionnaires et un magistrat ces
commissions examinons chaque dossier et
pourront réduire ou effacer complètement
les dettes prolongée et moduler les
échéances selon les revenus
enfin suspendre le cas échéant les
poursuites engagées
c'est un décret qui est qui traduit un
esprit certainement très nouveau qui
peut être très positif dans la mesure où
les circulaires d'application auquel
nous souhaitons que le recours soit
associée dans leurs études soit très
généreuse et très libérale et nous
attendons du ministre jacques dominati
lors de sa venue à toulouse vendredi
prochain où nous nous réunissons
d'ailleurs dans le cadre du recours
autour du processeur gonnard une
déclaration qui permet d'apporter toutes
les précisions et les améliorations vous
et je peux vous assurer que en publiant
ce décret est aujourd'hui même
sans attendre le projet de loi sur
l'indemnisation
le gouvernement montre sa détermination
il fait un très très gros effort et je
suis persuadé que les rapatrier en sont
conscients alors justement les rapatriés
attendre aussi ce projet de loi
d'indemnisation ce que
déjà nous en dire l'idée les grandes
lignes vous savez que c'est l'état
algérien selon les accords d'evian qui
était débiteur à l'égard des rapatriés
dans notre projet navigation nous disons
le c'est la communauté nationale qui en
fait son affaire et n'en fait pas son
affaire avec des bandes papier donc le
projet lisa sion sera court sera clair
il sera précis il permettra à 96% des
rapatriés de retrouver dans un temps
plus ou moins déterminé que les biens
96% de retrouver une compensation en ce
qui concerne leur patrimoine et les 96%
pratiquement totalement et je suis
persuadé là aussi que les rapatriés
seront satisfaits et ils seront surtout
à la fois moralement beaucoup plus
encore que matériellement et puis à
rennes 1 m'apprend que l'indemnisation
serait vraisemblement plafonné à 1
million de francs au lieu de 180 milles
actuelle des entretiens politiques de
raymond barre aujourd'hui d'abord avec
aimar achille fould le président de la
gauche réformatrice
puis henri caillavet avec lequel il
devait parler de télévision mais sans
doute aussi de bien d'autres choses
après edmond maire hier c'était au tour
de genre le cedi de prononcer
aujourd'hui son discours de rentrée
devant 15000 militants massés j'étais à
paris comme le secrétaire général de la
cfdt
georges séguy a lui aussi aborder
l'échéance politique de mars en répétant
bien qui n'était pas question pour la
cgt d'être complaisante vis-à-vis de
quiconque soutenu le programme comment
depuis cinq ans de toute notre énergie
et de toute notre autorité pour
consentir de main à la gauche
le sacrifice que nous refusons
aujourd'hui à la droite
le modèle de socialisme à la suédoise
n'a jamais été pour nous autre chose
qu'un mythe et nous ne voulons pas filé
le train au portugal
nous placent hors toujours du point de
vue des intérêts la classe ouvrière
l'essentiel pour nous est que le
gouvernement dispose des moyens
économiques indispensables à la
satisfaction des revendications des
travailleurs
si pour cela il s'avère nécessaire
comme la cgt le propose de procéder à
deux ou trois nations la sonorisation de
plus et de faire payer davantage les
riches ni travailleurs pourront pas
mardi avec l'annoncé du budget 78 nous
avons entrepris hier un tour d'horizon
de ce qui se passait dans la capitale
étrangère en matière de relance
économique après rome et londres hier
soir aujourd'hui bonne michel meyer
c'est le 14 septembre prochain que le
gouvernement allemand annoncera
officiellement son plan de relance
le but de ce plan est de diminuer si
possible le chômage qui touche
actuellement un million de travailleurs
mais aussi à titre préventif de faire
face à une augmentation de ce chômage
que les spécialistes prévoient dans le
courant de cet hiver
la formule allemande en discussion
s'oriente vers une relance de la
consommation des ménages et une relance
des investissements cela par le biais de
dégrèvements d'allègements fiscaux qui
tous feront autant les ménages
c'est-à-dire les contribuables
particuliers que les entreprises
ainsi quelques 8 milliards de
deutschemarks seront en quelque sorte
injectés dans les circuits économiques
allemands ils permettront aux allemandes
acheter plus et aux chefs d'entreprise
d'investir de façon plus importante
autre instrument anti récession made in
germany
le gouvernement allemand prévoit un
budget 78 un budget fédéral qui sera
plus important que celui de cette année
est en déficit déficit considérable de
l'ordre de 100 milliards de nos francs
encore une nouvelle à prendre avec des
pincettes idi amin dada ce serait dans
le coma après avoir subi une
intervention chirurgicale mais les
péripéties du maréchal ougandais nous
ont suffisamment échaudés pour que nous
ne développons pas plus cette info
conditionnel je rappelle signature hier
soir en présence de 25 chefs d'état ou
de gouvernement du nouveau traité sur le
canal de panama signature qui n'est pas
échappé à la traditionnelle photo de
famille moraliste comme à son habitude
jimmy carter a rappelé qu'à cette
occasion il n'entendait que dorénavant
la correction remplace la force dans les
relations entre les etats-unis et les
autres pays il reste maintenant aux
sénateurs américains à ratifier ce
traité
ce qui ne sera pas facile demain sera à
jour férié dans un département français
et oui la corse fait le 33ème
anniversaire de sa libération
et les élus locaux de l'île à
l'exception des socialistes et des
communistes à l'appel de cinq
parlementaires ont manifesté vont
manifester contre le séparatisme et les
violences d'où qu'elles viennent
pour mieux comprendre le climat
particulier de l'île aujourd'hui le
reportage et bernard marck et jacques
touristique estivale s'est retiré les
corps se retrouvent seuls avec leurs
problèmes
les familles dispersées les villages
vides et les villes morne septembre
c'est comme le petit jour après une nuit
blanche c'est l'heure de la lucidité et
cette année le premier bilan qu'il faut
dresser c'est celui de la violence
elle a atteint son apogée le 12 août
avec la destruction par explosif du
réémetteur de télévision de bastia 3
milliards d'anciens francs de dégâts
dans la moitié de la corse
25000 téléviseur muet ont tout à coup
porté témoignage de la détermination des
hommes du front de libération national
corse le flnc clandestins qui réclame
l'indépendance de l'île c'est son 44e
plasticage dans le nord de la corse en
un an
mais il n'a pas le monopole des
attentats cette carte montre la
répartition géographique des actions
violentes commises entre le 15 août 1976
et le 15 août 1977
mais l'action contre l'émetteur a donné
au flnc une dimension que jusqu'ici on
lui refusait avec l'arrivée des renforts
de police et de gendarmerie à un
important dispositif de surveillance a
été mise en place
interpellations et perquisitions ont
commencé peu après la chasse au flnc est
ouverte
sans succès jusqu'à présent les préfets
ont reçu des directives du chef de
l'état lui-même faire respecter les lois
et défendre l'unité nationale encore ce
même les élus pour la première fois
reconnaissent l'existence du mouvement
séparatiste le problème est posé il a
été posée en termes clairs
peut-être n'est-il pas posée par une
fraction importante de la population de
l'île jeu superbe d'ailleurs persuadé
qu'il en est ainsi qu il soit posée par
une minorité ou qu'ils soient posées par
quelque chose d'important
il est posé le soutien actif des élus
réclamée par le préfet de région a
trouvé son moyen d'expression devant les
monuments aux morts des deux chefs lieux
ils sont appelés ses élus à se
rassembler le 9 septembre anniversaire
de la libération de la corse
oui il nous a paru utile en lançant cet
appel de démontrer à l'opinion publique
et nationale qui parfois s'interroge sur
la corse que tous les élus et la
population
les deux départements rejette et rejette
totalement la violence et tout ce qui
pourrait être interprété comme un
relâchement des liens acide cela les
sentimentaux qui nous unissent et nous
unissent pour toujours à la mère-patrie
pour les élus donc seul le séparatisme
met en cause les partisans de
l'autonomie dans le cadre français
l'union du peuple corse et son leader
edmond simeoni aurait-il après le succès
populaire de leur meeting du 14 août
trouvé grâce aux yeux des parlementaires
chefs des deux clans politiques qui se
partagent la corse que veulent donc
prouver les élus corses réussi leur
manifestation servir est elle de caution
à une répression plus énergique et en
cas d'échec signifierait tel pour autant
que le séparatisme aurait marqué des
points
les avocats leur tour se sentent
concernés par les sciences politiques de
mars on le voit bien dans le thème de
l'heure
tiens traditionnel de nanterre qui sont
au barreau ce que les entretiens de
bichat sont à la médecine un exemple le
débat d'aujourd'hui que vannes ou résumé
paul lefèvre la sécurité publique est
elle compatible avec les libertés
individuelles
on s'en servent à l'essentiel montant
magistrats avocats et juristes
s'interrogent
peut-on à notre époque examiner sans
passion la contradiction apparente entre
d'une part les besoins que les français
ont d'être protégé contre les agressions
physiques politiques économiques leur
sécurité et l'autre par le désir
viscéral qui l'ont de voir leur liberté
personnelle respecter et tente car notre
société industrielle avec ses
ordinateurs ces règlements ces
psychiatres débouche sur une
réglementation qui ampute peu à peu la
liberté de chaque homme ainsi par
exemple est il normal qu'on oblige
chacun à porter une ceinture de sécurité
ou à se faire vacciner atteinte à la
liberté au choix personnel pour éviter
les dépenses à la sécurité sociale
organisme communautaire était normal que
pour lutter contre la criminalité
on pénètre par la fouille des voitures
dans le domaine privé de chacun en bref
est il possible de réaliser un équilibre
entre la sécurité générale et la liberté
individuelle
je ne sais pas s'il est possible mais je
pense qu'il est nécessaire et que l'une
société ne peut pas vivre si elle ne
fait pas ça pas à l'un et à l'autre des
deux éléments est ce qu'on pensait que
le droit de la communité pèse plus lourd
que les libertés individuelles ce qui
est prioritaire par rapport aux libertés
des individus dans les faits il
tomberait à être prioritaire me
semble-t-il révolution juridique des
dernières années va nettement dans le
sens d'un renforcement de la sécurité
donc ce qu'on appelle l'intérêt génère
l'intérêt général jeune tchèque pas sûr
que précisément ce ne soit pas cette
tendance
ode à l'hypertrophie de la
réglementation qui ne suffit pas en
contrepartie toute une série de
revendications plus aiguë de lit
berthé et le refus de ces
réglementations au risque d'aboutir à
des clients encore plus profond bon vent
à vsd vsd fait vendredi samedi dimanche
le nouvel hebdomadaire que lance maurice
siégeaient les jeux du set pour ma part
d'avoir la chance du magazine
l'expansion qui vient de fêter
aujourd'hui ses 10 ans avec un gros
numéro qui dresse un bilan des dix
dernières années et ouvre des
perspectives sur les dix ans à venir
mais revenons à vsd il n'en est pas
encore là et qui a l'ambition de
s'inscrire dans un créneau
particulièrement désert la presse du
week-end
un hebdomadaire de fin de semaine vsd
une idée de maurice sié j'ai 58 ans
ancien directeur général d' europe 1 un
temps ça suffit
il repart pour une nouvelle aventure
jean gaury ni avec siégel ils formaient
le tandem de choc de la radio pour vsd
leur chemin viennent à nouveau de se
croiser autour d'eux une équipe réduite
une trentaine de personnes
il sera fait appel à des collaborations
extérieures signatures connues pour la
plupart pour assurer les 64 pages du
journal
cela fait plus de deux ans maintenant
que maurice siège elle travaille à son
projet en décembre dernier le premier
numéro zéro sortait depuis sept autres
ont été faits les sondages effectués
démontre qu'un journal de week end à une
excellente place à prendre
quant au fond il se veut également
originale les jours dans la rue en
parlant avec des gens aient un certain
nombre de sujets sur lesquels jardiner
pourquoi ça pourquoi il se passe quelque
chose et pas du tout celle que les
journalistes les réponses que je réalise
ponte année m'en apporte alors tout le
truc
callen tessier j'ai c'est de se dire si
on arrive à trouver le pourquoi il faut
se décarcasser pour pouvoir répondre à
cette question là l'intuition de ce gène
vérifier quand hip hop c'est que les
gens sont prêts dans ces trois jours du
week-end à ne pas être paresseux et ça
c'est un formidable pari
nous l'avons testé et nous avons vu
qu'un français sur points à des rêves
l'idée bien perçu il restait à trouver
des financiers
si elle gèle les a trouvés parmi ses
amis dit il
au total 8 millions de francs étaient
réunis en une espèce de coopérative
d'intérêt toucher les gens du week end
une démarche qui peut pourtant paraître
paradoxal les français ne lisent pas dit
on alors pourquoi un journal
quelle est la grande différence qui
sépare les gens du week-end des gens de
la semaine sont ces mêmes gens avec la
même tête le même car le même esprit les
mêmes sentiments mais il ya un fait
étonnant qui intervient il faut
simplement y penser c'est qu'on a faim
on a le temps et le temps c'est une
notion essentielle qu'on a oublié
alors c'est vrai on n'a plus le temps de
vivre on a le temps de penser à autre
chose je dirais tout simplement on a le
temps d'être intelligent alors si vous
prenez le temps de dire eh bien voilà je
pense avoir eu votre réaction je pense
que le problème que vous êtes posé cette
semaine c'est celui là
et si vous le développer je crois qu
enfin on retrouve une communication avec
le lecteur parce que je ne sais pas moi
j'entends tout le monde dire le mal du
siècle c'est le manque de communication
alors on va essayer de faire la
communication le pari est lourd les
ambitions de vsd sont de vendre 200
mille exemplaires du journal chaque
semaine les autres hebdomadaires ce du
lundi par exemple le risque peut-être de
réagir en essayant de paraître plus tôt
le vendredi pourquoi pas le rendre
d'observation commencera en tout cas à
partir de demain matin dans les kiosques
avec nous maintenant sophia loren sophia
loren qui vient de jouer un film qui
sort en ce moment en france une journée
particulière avec marcello mastroianni
ce que vous pourriez en un mot et nous
dire à peu près de quel rôle il s'agisse
pas un rôle très stable non c'est pas un
rôle très simple je fais je suis une
femme delphine une femme ordinaire très
pauvre avec marie et très quand les
grossier et vulgaire et je suis
naturellement l'esclave de la famille
qu'on veut l'enfant avec une demi
douzaine d'enfants et j'ai toujours vécu
dans cette résignation toute ma vie qui
si nous voulons pas nous rendre compte
en est prêt et près un jour j'ai
rencontré un homme tel que moi mais qui
est bien plus qu on dirait jean cohésion
des plus grands problèmes de résistance
et voilà ma belle tranquillité de femmes
ignorante cv nuit et je trouve
je trouve la joie et la souffrance ce
que lauren quand on est une star
est-ce que c'est facile de jouer le rôle
d'une femme ordinaire
une femme de 40 ans une femme qui
parfois peut être l'aide et je crois que
dans notre métier il faut savoir tout
faire et surtout quand on est approché
par l'auteur et par l'intérêt scène je
parle de scola dans ce cas là avec un
sujet comme les journées particulières
il faut faire n'importe quoi pour être
vraiment bien dans une histoire pareille
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui
finalement il n'y a pas tellement de
belles histoires pour les femmes je sais
pas pourquoi parce qu'il paraît que les
hommes clés sur le mât pour les hommes
et quand on trouve un rôle comme ça il
faut aller jusqu'au bout et faire
n'importe quoi pour que ça sort merci se
fier là très rapidement le tiercé
d'aujourd'hui le 17 le 13 et le 14 une
course disputée cet après midi à
vincennes et puis la météo est bien
l'automne arrive vraiment trop vite le
ciel sera très maussade avec des averses
au nord de la loire au sud du fleuve
bien grosso modo le temps persistera
sont de l'aven je vous souhaite à tous
une excellente soirée merci de nous
avoir écoutés six derniers rendez vous
avec l'information vers 23h avec betty
du rau a donné